pelaton is in a world of hurt after
being exposed By Dana White and Theo Von
during a conversation about podcast
advertisers where it came out that
pelaton had demanded Theo remove his
episode with Robert Kennedy Jr their
company's about to go public or
something they're like this could ruin
everything that's what our Ad Agency
said to us they's worried this could
ruin everything it's 8:00 at
night on a Friday or something turns out
everything did end up getting ruined for
pelaton because right after Dana White
heard Theo's story of this arrogant
request he person saw to it that every
pelaton bike was removed from the UFC
training facility that same day do we
have pelons in the gym are those
pelaton asport no no there's bikes next
to it asport as yeah we're getting rid
of them y we're getting rid of the
patons a company that just sells
stationary bikes trying to dictate who
theovon is allowed to talk to is pretty
ridiculous but that's probably why